you can absorb
light I can see it and Camala who's
Camala hi she can turn light into
physical matter I could totally show you
no Nia first of all congratulations on
the film and I really want to start here
because I know for a lot of folks Marvel
is maybe something they maybe want to do
but for you this was a passion this was
a nerdy expertise and it started with a
crazy pitch to Kevin feige so I'd love
for you to talk about your Marvel fandom
and how this started with that pitch oh
it didn't start with a crazy pitch I
waited till I was inside they hired me
and then I was like Kevin I'm like hello
here all my
ideas um no I um you know my initial
conversations were with um Mary leanos
the exec on this film and she basically
told me that they wanted to have the
three women in the film that they're
going to be switching places and she
told me about some of the sequences that
they wanted to do in the film and I was
like oh this is going to be really
exciting this is going to be really fun
and different and uh and so when I went
into pitch my big thing was like on one
hand here so I would do some of these
big sequences and these set pieces and
on the other hand like here's the
emotional underpinning that I want to
bring into this film um and so that's
kind of how we we got started well the
emotional underpinning really sort of I
think lies within these very three
unique incredibly powerful women but the
relationship everyone's very interested
in is Carol and Monica and where they
are can you talk a little bit about
where they are in the characters and
really what Tiana and Bri wanted to
bring to this very interesting family
reunion for sure um yeah I mean everyone
watched W Division and saw that look
Monica gave where she was like Carol you
know and I I was shook when I saw that
and so to be able to actually be the one
to show what it was and see them kind of
reconcile was really exciting um yeah
Carol's got the Universe on her
shoulders she's got this burden she
feels this burden to to take care of
everyone in the universe you know and
and obviously that's an impossible job
and I think we explore that psychology
we explore what that is for her but also
we were able to just show Monica dealing
with grief like not just the loss of her
mother but also the loss of her her Aunt
the other thing I really want to talk
about and you've already alluded to it
we see a little bit in the commercials
and that is the fight sequences in this
I mean the way their powers sort of
combin in this moment we kind of see
them switching we know from Miss Marvel
that the outof body experiences are real
talk about how difficult that was to set
up those action sequences knowing these
actors were going to be changing and the
work they had to do for that yeah so
first of all they are amazing um Bri
everyone knows she she works out she
gets strong she really wants to be
prepared for this um Iman and Tiana like
did the same they were just they were so
amazing and they were
so physical and they were so inside of
it and also you know especially with
with Tiana like talking about what
Monica was going to do like wanting
there to be a journey inside of the
physicality of these fight scenes it's
like she's learning how to use his pow
so she'll get better as the movie goes
on um and so as someone who loves fight
scene like good fight scenes it was a
real privilege to be able to do to do a
bunch in this film but also to figure
out how to map the powers into it and
the switching into it so for me
initially it was like started on the
page it's like okay we have especially
that big first fight scene I tried to be
really specific when we were writing it
because that was going to be the map
that everyone used to figure out okay
this this fight chunk will be this and
this and that and that and this person
will be switching here and then we'll
stay here and then you know it's like
but because it's so chaotic we really
wanted to have like a road map and then
we get all the department head heads in
and we figure out okay what's going to
be second unit what's going to be main
unit what's going to be V effect what's
going to be practical what are the
passes we need to do for one moment like
because every switch that we have you
have the first actor and the second
actor the background you know maybe
something else to come in have a pass
with the lighting so that we have like
these bracelets that light up so that we
have actual interactive light you know
so many things to think about and I have
the best ad in the world Jack Ravens
crof so he was able to just like
organize it all for us and then at the
end of the day when it was time to shoot
it was just about getting the call sheo
I do love that and you make it sound
easy but like literally in my head I'm
like but wait but what happens when you
have to then move in the stunt director
it's like well we need this shot on her
and I I really love how in all of that
you still got their like sisterly
Dynamic of all of these women talk about
that in particular because it's very
interesting it's new superhero that's
maybe better at their powers than the
like they they sort of between them as
women but then also as superheroes have
different places that they sort of are
so talk about how they became this again
Trio of Power and Light I think what's
great about them is that they have
different connections with each other or
at least Kamala and Monica have a
different connection with with Carol and
those connections that they have they're
so integral in their own individual
development and also in integral to them
becoming a team and so you know when we
meet Carol like I think she's a little
jaded she's been doing this for a very
long time she's really isolated and then
you have her niece who is upset with her
and then you have this girl who thinks
like she's the best thing in the world
and so I think living in that the three
of them they start to learn how to be a
team and work together Kamala has to
realize she's also just a human being
you know even though she is Captain
Marvel and Monica also has to realize oh
she's had to be Captain Marvel um she's
not just my aunt so you know I think it
helps that Dynamic was really important
to me and it was really fun to to put
together um I know in this process you
talked to a lot of other Marvel
directors sort of like going into be
like all right put me in coach what what
advice do you have and I loved that you
said that Ryan cougler simple advice was
be yourself yeah he's just just a good
guy really is though good human yeah
very much so but I'm curious what did
that mean on set for you and how did you
make this movie how did you stay true to
that onset so one of the biggest things
for me was that this was a joyful
experience um talking to Bri we both
were like this has to be fun we're
making a superhero movie you know like
we get to do this it's amazing so um
when I was hiring every department head
you know I that was a big thing I said
one it's like no like I you know don't
deal with yellers or drama or any of
that um but the other thing is like
let's bring a group of people together
who are yes talented yes amazing other
jobs but also are dedicated to like Good
Vibes Vibes only so yeah for me that was
really important and that's how I kind
of approach all of my work and knowing
that I could take that and put it and
bring it on this really big um scale was
really really gratifying I love that
Good Vibes only like put some Sage get
some good music on start smudging
seriously uh I would think that says to
the vibe of this film because the thing
I really like that to see is how funny
it is how funny Sam is how funny Bri is
talk about how y'all sort of dialed up
the last for this one because I really
do think people are going to be
surprised with how zany and chaotic it
is from the most serious moments of
emotion to these like crazy fight
sequences yeah coming into the movie I
was like the movie has to be funny like
and also my DP and I were talking about
it we're like it has to be funny um
because I think for me and it wasn't
like this have a joke every minute it
was more like when you're with your
friends you're laughing so much you know
and I think the warmth that I wanted to
have on set and to be on in the movie I
think humor naturally comes out of that
and so I thought I was like if we can
they're all really funny in different
ways the the three leads like on their
personal lives and so I was like if we
can bring that to them into onto screen
and we can like lean on the con family
too CU they're so funny and wonderful
but a lot of that comes from warmth and
and that feeling of family then we'll
not just have a funny movie and a fun
movie but we'll also have a movie that
feels really real and human the other
thing I want to talk about we've already
talked a lot about a BRI and her coming
back from the second iteration what do
you think folks are going to be most
surprised about folks that were huge
fans of the first Captain Marvel in this
one what are they going to see this time
from Carol that maybe they haven't seen
before uh the rainbow Crocs okay
girl and everything those represent
that's going to be they're going to be
like what when I can't wait okay rainbow
Crocs I now have that and I'm going to
be thinking Laren H about that uh
another person that you had on set for
this one that's part of the original
Captain Marvel is Samuelson and like I
would say if I'm going to start my first
Marvel movie I'd like to have him in it
because it's sort of like you get all
the encyclopedic knowledge what do you
think he sort of brought again as sort
of the Elder Statesman of the MCU quite
literally giving birth to it The
Avengers literally what did he sort of
like tell you about on set because I
know he's also very like that person on
set that would you know be like hey you
got it he was so generous and supportive
and not not just with me but also with
the rest of the cast he's so wonderful
he was so wonderful to work with and
because he is the elder Statesman of the
MCU he's like the dad of the MCU that's
really what we how we wanted to kind of
portray him in this film so he spends a
lot of time with the con family because
you know it's kamala's parents and the
parent the dad of the MCU like worried
for their girls you know and so and so
you know he's been through a lot uh in
the MCU um you know he's been a lot and
through a a lot in secret Invasion and
and we get to have him here kind of
being where I think a lot of people love
him just being the guy who's like you
guys got this go off and be amazing yeah
yeah that's what you need at this point
like a very like proud dad at graduation
type moment and his and Breeze Dynamic
again hugest tragedy that they're not
here is that I get to talk to the two of
them just bust on each other um the
other thing I did want to talk to you
about is because this is an MCU movie
and like I do have to say getting the
Marvel is the same year we got Beyonce I
feel like there was black girl magic
that had to have it and I felt that in
the needle drops just talk about some of
the really awesome I think music that
you guys used in this one to sort of
like drive that one and the Miss Elliott
yes I mean like literally like it's
really that was that something that was
from the script or did you guys come to
that later uh we had a different song
initially it was also it was also um a
black artist um but um you know one of
the um so my editor Katrina ham who
we've worked together for literally
everything I've ever done including
ining um my shorts including top boy
which had a lot of needle drops she is a
master of needle drops and so inner
Stellar is a big one that she was like
what if we did this Boop and I was like
that's perfect thank you you know and um
and I'm pretty
sure CU it's like who did what who knows
but I'm pretty sure she also dropped
that Miss Elliot in there and so like
the Mind melt happening is always great
but yeah like I think this is what
happens when you have like long-term
collaborators what happens when you have
like women women of color or like you
know you just get more of that kind of
culture in into into the film flavor it
is all about the flavor and again with
these three leads they bring it from
like the jump yeah the other thing I
will say is look you haven't talked
about it I want to talk about X-Men like
I really want to say this cuz like we
haven't even said the MW and you've been
like keeping your fandom in check but I
think I've talked to you on other movies
about how you're like no the MCU is
going to be different when we hit this
pH so talk about how it's like you're
directing the first film that really
leans into the idea that we have mutants
in the MCU yes I you know what's funny I
didn't even think about it because like
this we not it doesn't really have
anything to do with it but Kamala is a
mutant and I'm so Happ what he doesn't
have anything to do with it hold up in
the sense of like in the sense of like
it wasn't like you know Charles Xavier
wasn't like hello welcome you know what
I mean it's it's really about these
three women but it's cool to have like
you know a woman who got her powers
because she walked through her radiating
she'll Mar for witch X and another one
who got her poers an explosion and
another one who got them because she's a
mutant you know it's just really it's
really cool to see oh my God actually
Nick Fury is the bald guy in this one so
there's connections everywhere all right
I'm GNA ask another risky one here
because look we we know what happens
right we know that there's going to be a
moment after the credits yes just tell
me like this is me and you here so like
don't play the like I'm a Marvel
director let's talk like this is this is
me no one's here no one was here yes
come on so what what can we look what we
so what happens is um the tag in the tag
it is the best uh tag
ever she said that it's one I think it's
one of the
best genuinely okay yeah any give me a
word give me something that tells me
what I can look forward with this just
like a little song Give me The Vibes
here we go give me The Vibes of the
after credit scene uh the word would be
huh question mark girl that's the Vibes
of all of
them I think especially right now seeing
women team up this is such a great
moment but with these three particular
identities of these three women right
now what would you say to ladies who are
like cuz I feel like this is another
chance to have a Barbie moment of women
empowerment to come and have like a real
like awesome female empowerment type
superhero story so what would you say to
the ladies who you want to maybe get
tickets for for Captain Marvel's like
why they should
it's I think what's great is that we
have three very different women at the
center of the film and you know
sometimes when you have uh a movie about
a woman hero the onus is on them to
represent every woman but that's not
possible instead of have three women you
know we get a little bit more you know
covered but it's really great to see how
different they are and and in their
differences I think it allows people to
realize they can be whoever they are and
that's beautiful and wonderful so if you
want to have a good time with three
amazing women who make you feel good
about yourself I think you should come
the
movie